BRIAN GRADY: Hi.
My name is Brian Grady.
And I'd like to welcome you all
here to the very first Silicon
Valley Video Producers meetup.
AUDIENCE: Woo!
BRIAN GRADY: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
Thank you very much for coming.
We're all really
excited about this.
When I say "we,"
I mean the group
of people that I work with
and my mom, and my wife.
But I'm excited
about it personally,
because to tell
you the truth, I'm
not a Silicon Valley native.
I just fell in here two
years ago to work at Google
and produce video for the
Google Developer Studio.
And we have a YouTube channel.
I'll tell you more about
that in a little bit.
But I'm excited because yeah, I
want to learn about 360 Video.
But I also want to
meet a lot of people
in the area that
do stuff that I do,
and do stuff like that I do,
and do stuff better than I do.
And so I think maybe
you guys are all here.
I'm also really, really glad--
I'm looking around the room,
and I'm really glad that we
have a great range of diversity
in the room.
So I think we should
all get a hand for that.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
So let's get the
show on the road.
Who are we?
And I say "we"-- I mean us,
because we're a community,
and that's what
we're here to build.
We're anyone who works in video
production in Silicon Valley.
Right?
Do we work in video production?
And we want to be
inclusive all the way
to the top, San Francisco, and
we want to include East Bay.
If we can get people down from
East Bay, we'd be very happy.
Anybody come down
from the East Bay?
[CHEERS]
Oh, yeah!
I live in Emeryville.
So thank you for coming.
And I think we all
work in a wide variety
of formats and techniques.
And I think it's great when
we get together and sort
of share ideas and mix it up.
It's probably a lot of us,
because of where we are,
we have tech industry clients.
Anybody have tech
industry clients here?
A few people.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I am one.
BRIAN GRADY: You are one.
I'll give you my card.
No.
Everybody give him their card.
Yes.
And even though we're
in Silicon Valley,
I'm sure that we have a wide
range of different sorts
of programs that we create.
And so I'm hoping that we have
people from these four and more
markets.
Who am I?
I'm Brian Grady.
I'm a video producer.
I'm the creative director
at Google Developer Studio.
And what do we do?
We're in the Scalable
Developer Outreach team.
And what that is is we are
reaching out to developers
all over the world
in massive numbers,
educating them,
and inspiring them
to get their shit right on
the Google Developer Platform.
And they need some help.
So we provide that.
There are a lot of
different-- let's
say we have a diverse audience
of people that are interested
and who have never done it.
We have people that
they have some ideas,
but they're maybe
not developers,
but they want to
become developers.
Then we have really
solid developers.
And we have Steve [? Joffe ?]
in the back of the room here.
Thank you, Steve, for coming.
We have people that are very far
up the curve that are working
in startups and partners.
And they need help with
developing software.
And that's what the guys
that we put on camera, that's
what they do.
So check out our
YouTube channel.
Does anybody want to see a
little taste of what we do?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: Of course.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-The amount of content that's
been created has exploded.
-That's exciting.
-And they'll broadcast that
information 1 to 10 times
a second.
-We need to make sure
that this data gets
into the hands of as
many people as possible.
-And here's where you
developers come in.
-The app universe is enormous.
-Your life as a
developer can be easier
and more successful by taking
advantage of our guidance.
-So you can make decisions
based on concrete data.
-With this one weird trick.
[MOANING]
-That's nuts.
-Every single release has new
stuff that you can talk about.
And in the process
of that, you may
forget your personal security.
[DING]
-The best practices
are important,
and we really
thought them through.
-Let's see this in action.
-Can we roll that video?
[BRAKES SCREECH]
[CHICKEN  SCREECHES]
-Guilty.
-And that's it.
-Join us.
-We can't wait to
see what you build.
-Thank you for watching.
-Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
You see a couple
of our other shows.
We built a couple of, I
think, pretty impressive--
let's kill this real
quick-- impressive brands.
So I said we have
a diverse audience.
We have diverse work.
We saw there's a show I do
called "Coffee with a Googler."
That's just two
people sitting down,
talking about what it's
like to work at Google
and what they work on.
All those people that you
saw in front of their slide
shows, we call
those "Dev Bytes."
And those are quick, targeted
little pieces of information
that developers need
to get their job done.
And if you notice the
kiosks around here,
you'll see more examples
of our work there.
And you should
check out the page.
Our team.
Team lead is Jamie Baughman.
Production-- myself, Liza
Patnoe, and Nilesh Bell-Gorsia
are the production leads.
Nilesh is in London.
Our post-production
leader is Gabe Pannel.
Program management is
done by Daniel Pham.
And we have an army
of producers-- sorry,
production teams and
post-production people that
really make everything work.
Like you guys all know that
it's not the names on here
that do all the work, right?
It's the other
guys in the studio.
So anyway, we have three
channels-- Google Developers,
Android Developers,
and Chrome Developers.
And I would
encourage you, if you
know any developers, to
please introduce them
to the channel for us.
Here's tonight's agenda.
And we sort of switched it up
from the original announcement,
but what we're going to do is
have a colleague of ours, Neil,
come up and give us a
little inspirational talk
about where we are with 360
and where's the potential.
Then we have our talk
from Anjali Wheeler,
who we are very glad came to
us from YouTube to show us
how to implement 360 Video.
We're going to talk about
Jump with Todd Shaiman.
We'll take a little break.
Then we're going to hear
from Stephen Fromkin, who
is a producer at 360Heros.
And he's going to
show us what they do.
Then we're going
to do a Q&A panel.
And we'll have a little raffle.
We have some awesome prizes.
And one thing I've been
wanting to say for a while
is we have a gift for everybody.
[CHEERS]
[APPLAUSE]
Who doesn't have Cardboard?
Who needs Cardboard?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
BRIAN GRADY: OK, you
guys all get Cardboard.
[CHEERS]
And the rest of you,
you get Cardboard, too!
That's awesome.
Thank you.
All right.
So on your way out,
grab a Cardboard.
You know what Cardboard is?
OK, good.
Excellent.
We also have wonderful
raffle tickets
that you have to
stay till the end.
We have a GoPro that
we're going to give away.
AUDIENCE: Oh, snap.
AUDIENCE: 360 [INAUDIBLE]?
BRIAN GRADY: Not
the 360, I'm sorry.
Just the one [? GoPro. ?]
But if you get five more,
then you can make the rig.
All right.
So Google Developer Studio
is sponsoring the evening.
And if anybody here
would like to get
involved in the sponsorship,
it might be pretty interesting.
If you have any suggestions
for a next meetup
or one in the future, I already
have one set up for October
pretty much.
But please do contact me
if you have any questions
or suggestions.
And we're back at the agenda.
That's not nice.
Actually, this is
the next meetup.
I wanted to let you know that
Suny Behar is a director,
cinematographer, and educator.
He ran a program for us down
at the Red Studios in LA
a couple of months ago.
We had a great time.
Very knowledgeable,
great speaker.
So he's going to be at
the next meetup October 1.
[MUSIC PLAYING]